So here are some of the Blondie lyrics we want to display.
We can see that it starts out with the chorus.
Once I had a love and it was a gas,
soon found out had a heart of glass.
Seemed like the real thing only to find mucho mistrust, love's gone behind.
And then these same lines are repeated later on in the song.
And to display these lyrics on a karaoke machine,
we can write out a block of code to print this chorus and other lyrics.
And for a chorus, we can copy and paste the same code again wherever the chorus appears.
But repeating the same code again like this should be avoided.
For example, what if we wrote chorus code with a small spelling error.
We wrote live instead of love,
and we found this error only after we'd copy and pasted it.
When we did find the small error,
we'd have to check all the places or course code appears
and go to each place and change the blocks of code individually.
This isn't too bad for two copies of
the same thing but it could get out of hand very quickly,
and it can be a lot of work for one small change.
Wouldn't it be useful to group our course code
together so that we can reuse it and change it easily?
Well, we can. Java let's us group code together in something called a function.
Functions hold all the instructions and
decision making that's performed in a specific task.
Even something like printing out a chorus in a song.
So we can group these four lines of code together in one function and
any changes we make in that function will effect everywhere that it's used automatically.
In this lesson, we'll will learn all about functions and how to create our own.